welcome my name is Matthew Mian I am the
director of academic programs here at
the Kirby Center for Hillsdale in DC and
the Worsham Teaching Fellow it's
wonderful to have you all here for this
very important topic Hillsdale College
in DC we are liberal arts college and
the Kirby Center cares about
constitutional study and citizenship and
part of the liberal arts and way of
retranslated that same phrase might be
the arts of Liberty the arts of
self-government both of the soul to be
free but also of the city to live in a
self governed way and part of the issue
tonight is self-government tonight mr.
Brown John Brown will be delivering his
talk and presentation on how to think
about brexit and it's pertains very much
to this question of self-government so
without further ado let me introduce mr.
Brown John Brown is a partner in Frayser
Brown and Mayor LLC an economic and
financial data firm a former
Conservative member of parliament he is
a graduate of the Royal Military Academy
Sandhurst the Cranfield Institute of
Technology and Harvard University after
graduation from Harvard John spent time
as a somewhat unskilled cowboy on a
working ranch in Wyoming
you'll see the Renaissance man theme
runs deep in this bio he retired as a
major from the Grenadier Guards having
served as a pilot and a parachutist on
public duties he had responsibility for
the pallbearers at the state funeral of
Sir Winston Churchill a fond favourite
here amongst Hillsdale IANS his picture
his painting is there in the vestibule
of the hall he worked mr. Brown worked
at Morgan Stanley as an investment
banker and at the European banking
company where he became director of
Middle East operations mr. Brown also
served as vice-president of the UK
Independence Party you may have heard of
the Independence Party which championed
and won brexit in June 2016 during his
time in Parliament he was appointed as
personal liaison to Mikhail Gorbachev on
his first official visit to the West and
he briefed Prime Minister Thatcher with
whom he worked closely on the Soviet
leader and helped to bridge the gap he
is the author of two books which I have
to stop for a moment and mention hidden
account of the Romanovs which is a
fictional historical fiction a novel
that gets into the internecine
relationships between the West blad Amir
Putin the Bank of England and Rasputin
so from Putin to Rasputin it's quite a
thing and also a memoir called the
Grenadiers grins about his his time with
the Grenadier Guards so without further
ado it is my great honor to introduce a
Renaissance man mr. John Brown
[Applause]
well good evening ladies and gentlemen
Thank You Matthew for those kind and
very exaggerated words my goodness
what a wonderful audience I was
expecting about 10 or 15 people and it
must be the subject that strongly rather
than my speaking ability but all
politicians particularly failed
politicians or past politicians are
always glad to have an audience of more
than one and I had an amazing thing
happened to me I was invited to speak at
a financial conference in Hong Kong and
that was all arranged and then suddenly
the Federal Reserve Board of
Philadelphia asked if I could speak just
before it and it fitted it perfectly
London to Philadelphia dive do the talk
at the lunch there and then fly
overnight over the pole to Hong Kong
just in time for their opening keynote
speech of their three-day conference and
it all went well got over to
Philadelphia and then it was a tornado
which hit the International Terminal and
damaged the roof so severely that all
international flights were put back 24
hours so I arrived in Hong Kong
almost exactly a 24 hours late and the
organizers were not best pleased and so
I was put rescheduled to the very end of
the conference 2:30 on Friday afternoon
and as after lunch on Friday I thought
my god I wonder if anyone will turn up
so I went along at about 10:00 past 2 to
this vast auditorium I mean 3,000 plus
seater huge thing I mean it was amazing
and it was totally empty there was not a
single soul
and then at twenty past two a man
arrived and he turned out to be the
moderator and we were just about to
leave both of us when another man
arrived and slap smacked down in the
middle of the front row right and in the
center of the auditorium so I had to
give my speech to an audience of one and
of course he was a wonderful audience of
one he laughed in the right places
clapped in the right vision so when it
all over this agony I went to thank the
moderator and I thought I must thank
this gentleman who's come and listened
and so I went to thank him and then I
started to go up the aisle myself away
and he said oh where are you going I
said I'm going shopping he said well
please don't go and I said why not he
said I'm the next speaker
[Music]
so so so thank you very much indeed for
turning up this evening I apologize in
advance to these poor luckily young
people here on the left-hand side for
the Crick neck they'll probably have by
the end of this evening because this is
a PowerPoint I did for you and I thought
this screen was going to be behind me so
but that's what we've got to look at for
a bit it's a great honor to speak here
at his day because Hillsdale to me is a
bastion of the sort of things I believe
in and I should say that I'm a bit of a
mongrel here I was born an English
subject and elected to be an American
citizen I'm no George Washington but
that's the sort of thing that he did too
and so when I look at these people
behind me my English hats is this rabble
of revolutionaries and my American hats
these heroes of today and I treat them
as heroes because the Constitution is
one of the finest documents ever written
and it will last many hundred years as
long as it's obeyed I think in terms of
democracy and representative democracy
not just a Moxley but real
representation we've had many pretenses
of democracy which really weren't any
democracy at all you know justified to
see a bit about one of them and so to
talk about brexit brexit is a massive
event historical event absolute massive
it's going to affect greatly the United
States Europe Britain of course the
Commonwealth which is 1.2 billion people
and the world I would say and it's going
to be a great battle that's either won
or lost and leading to the future
between professional state apparatus and
the people so it's a great battle for
democracy or representative democracy
now I'm biased I have to say in that it
shows it here but I just arrived home
what I say got to take sometimes with a
bit of salt
because that's my you Kip what's it
called election pamphlet that was
circulated to say to God to do that one
and so I declare that bias and just to
talk about to greta quickly i've got a
rattle through these slides because
really the question time is what i want
to get to it's probably going to be the
most exciting just so that everybody
understands when they see article fifty
written down article fifty is the
official application by a member of the
european union to leave and so you file
article fifty an applications lead under
article fifty and so a fifty wherever
you see it in print that's what it means
of course nobody's ever done it before
so we're in totally unprecedented
uncharted territory backstop is the
thing where the irish open border the
problem between northern and island and
southern island a complete red herring
created by may and probably marker to
take eyes off the customs union because
it means that britain's going to remain
on the custom in the customs union until
a solution comes to northern ireland
well the last solution took almost a
hundred years and so what it is is the
shorthand way between may and merkel of
saying we're staying in the european
union effectively and it's a complete
red herring one point six percent of
southern islands trade goes to northern
ireland it's a tiny amount and that's
the largest of the two parties so those
two things need explanation now politics
and power you're probably all students
politics politics is the practice of
power and knowledge is probably the
certainly a major power but probably the
major power it was knowledge that gave
us the agricultural industrial
revolutions it was knowledge that gave
us the nuclear weapon it's knowledge
about the enemy that allows you to be
very efficient in destroying the enemy
and so knowledge is the power and the
spread of knowledge is crucial to power
and lenin of course as a reminder was
the beginning of universal socialism of
global social and started when he
defeated the socialist
cause the Revolution when he took over
from them but very cleverly and the
Bolsheviks then took over and then
called themselves the Communists the
spread was to spread around the world
global socialism and I think you'll see
a thread stemming from theirs as I talk
now this is background knowledge this is
not facts of things this is having been
alive for about four times the length of
the average person here and having
experienced certain myths of history
like I'm I thought nothing of at the
time it was a great privilege
brightening I'm now one of the very few
people who's actually spoken to Winston
Churchill I realized that it's you know
once sort of almost a part of history
but these are the sort of lessons I've
learned fundamental lessons that are
important to this whole issue of brexit
the first rule in year I'm talking now
not of the Far East but of the
anglo-american world particularly Europe
and England that rule of the kings and
they had kingdoms and nations and
empires and then there was a magnet an
enormous erosion of political power with
the printing press because it allowed
those people who are educated to read
and become knowledgeable and that
created power and allowed them to be
knowledgeable in business agriculture
industry and so on the fact is that they
with the knowledge they were able to
accumulate wealth and that wealth meant
they became monitors of the government
they had power because of the wolf gave
them power to keep governments on track
and that's a crucial element to
democracy they basically forced to
marched in the end and when I was a
young lad I remember a village near me
if Tom Browns school days now where I
lived in Wiltshire my family home and
there was a man there in minority who
never been more than 15 miles from his
home his son was in the military in the
Second World War and he thought he'd
been to the moon to go to Germany in
France or something and he couldn't read
or write I mean the people ordinary
people couldn't First World War most
officers had to read the letters to
their men
letters back they had to write them to
their loved ones of family sweethearts
and things like that and even in my day
in the army when I joined there were
several people who still couldn't read
or write now it's changed and so more
people are able to have knowledge and
then the huge explosion was the release
of the internet which really gave huge
knowledge to everybody now everybody in
the world knows exactly what President
Trump should do over Iran and over every
other question they know precisely they
were always guessing in the Iraq war
exactly how he would attack you they've
created the Saddam Hussein and all that
says it I must say it wasn't all bad
because it must have confused the Iraqis
no end all these thousands of different
plans but there's now an effort as I see
it of a clawback that they want police
want this power back and the way to get
it is supranational governments and it
started long ago even before the in Adel
with the creation of central banks of
the United Nations a huge supranational
body the IMF the World Bank all these
bodies which really don't have any
democratic legitimacy at all that's sort
of like the House of Lords in a way but
on a vast national international scale
you just have to look at the banking
crisis in Cyprus where the central banks
and the IMF and the European European
Union got together and said right we're
going to confiscate deposits anybody
with a deposit of over a hundred
thousand dollars there's a hundred that
you might have had a million in there
we're taking nine hundred thousand you
know gan and a hundred thousand that all
started no democratic legitimacy at all
I'm in daylight robbery and it was done
in the open and they all approved it and
government is very remote I mean it's
remote enough for you and I when we vote
for a senator or a representative I mean
you try and go and see him or write to
him you get a standard letter back I
mean it's only the very few that get
real letters and get real access to
these people and when you find them
abroad I mean finally getting hold of a
European first of all all the
constituencies have seven members so
which member do you write to and so none
of them have a car
ability it all vanishes and so the worst
thing about it in the European Union is
the European Union is aiming at the
federal state and a federal state means
a total boss not the United States with
plural but a federal state singular the
first great experiment in a federal
state and that means the eradication of
nations and that's a big thing for
everybody
now Lenin as I said it was a mizuna
Versalles socialism his aim although he
offered peace bread and land very simple
election manifesto that even the
simplest illiterate people could
understand but what he gave was the
eradication of the middle class which
did away with any vestige of democracy
the impoverishment of the working class
and so everybody became dependent on the
state just look at some of politicians
in the Western world today giving
everything away the states getting
around everything education rid of the
the loans the blah blah blah all the
money will be come from some magic place
called the state and soon everything
will be provided by the state so if
you're against the government you're
against all your sources of living just
as when Gorbachev came and broke down
communism and in Soviet Union a lot of
people were against him because they
owed everything they had a massively
well-paid job food light energy all
housing all came from the state so why
do away with this communist state and so
all power rests in a global elite which
is much more remote than the Soviet
elite or the British or an American
elite here in Washington it's much more
about if it's on a global basis and
total power rests with them and then you
try to start a revolution but then when
they've got all sorts of electronic
thing and they control a world you can't
flee to anywhere as a revolutionary
president then where else to go they're
all in the thing so the great struggle
you and I everyone in this room faces
whether they know it or not is against
international progressive socialist
elite I call a nipsey which are
globalist some people call in the swamp
and the Oratia erosion of nationhood
it's become politically correct anything
you speak against it is politically
incorrect and I tend to be on the side
which says free-market capitalism and
nationhood and this is the biggest
struggle that's above all else I mean
there's career there's Iran as this is
that there's Democrat and Republican and
conservative and labor and brexit and
all that stuff going on but that is the
struggle that you really face it's going
to go on all our lives being gay on so
long that globalism is embedded in much
of the administration of most countries
in the Western world already so this is
a huge huge struggle now brexit in
essence is about national sovereignty or
nationhood with accountable democracy
and a restoration of the middle class
and the protection of the working class
that's basically what brexit is all
about there's lots of frills and things
about it but that in essence is what
brexit is for and it was a battle by the
population against the global elite and
2016 was an amazing year nobody thought
that brexit would win very very few
people that's the only reason that
Cameron a prime minister allowed the
referendum because he told everyone in
Europe and he thought himself quite
right and they had got no chance of
winning because they all watched the
polls and the same thing they said about
Trump not a chance I mean never comment
is not a million-in-one chance that he's
going to win a million to one odds I
never heard them even for outside horses
in the Kentucky Derby a million to one
when a hundred to one is staggering a
thousand one but a million to one is
absolute certainty because both they had
in common being a member of UK but
believing in brexit was very
unfashionable in Britain particularly
amongst the Conservative Party from
which most of the you kick members were
drawn who believed in nationhood and and
accountable government and things like
that
and America breaks it was very I mean
Trump was very
fashionable use people whispered his
name I remember sitting in a Yacht Club
in Palm Beach and an older woman was my
guest that evening and she lent to me
and she looked on either side to see if
anyone's listening she said what do you
think of mr. Trumbull and I said well
I've actually applied to be on his team
beyond his election team this was in
July of 2015 and I'd had dinner with him
and two other people in 2014 at
mar-a-lago when he got into the court he
said can I join you and so he joined us
there were three of us sitting there
including the owner of the newspaper for
which I wrote well known here Dick
Scaife and he said I'm thinking of
running for president it's the first
time I'd heard it was about 18 months
before he ran but this was an amazing
thing and it was very unfashionable so
when pollsters came around saying who
you gonna vote for so I'm voting
conservative I'm voting for Hillary he
never dared to say other than that or
they mob them up and said well of course
I'm voting conservative course I'm
voting for Hillary but underneath when
it came to the put their mark on the bad
there was a different story
and completely fooled the pollsters in
both countries it was a very similar
result for the same sort of reasons and
it's the same struggle and to understand
brexit we're just going to go rattling
through some slides now just talk about
the the evolution of the European Union
and why on earth Britain joined in the
first place well there's there's I'm not
going to read that one out but basically
he's saying that you know in order to
have defense where NATO is existed
already which was the real defense of
Europe and the only thing the Russians
were framed oh they would have run all
over us if it hadn't been for the
nuclear umbrella of the United States
and partially of Great Britain which had
American missiles the only country that
American trust America trusted with its
missiles so those were the things and
that was a very brilliant decision main
made
rather in the Bermuda agreement between
JFK and Harold Macmillan who got on very
well personally the America against the
advice of McNamara and people Kennedy
said yes we're gonna the British sees
missiles because it made the decision of
the Russians much more than twice as
difficult they had to work out in a
situation what does the president United
States gonna do but in and that's never
certain but what's he gonna do he also
had to work out what is the British
prime minister going to do and they're
not always the same in their shades of
difference between very confusing for
the enemy
it's like Iran at the moment I mean
Britain has a similar views sometimes
exactly the same sometimes slightly
different confusing for anyone that's
opposing this team and so that was a the
first thing of Monet who was one of the
architects now this one I am going to
read up because this is how it was done
this is an alleged statement not 100%
guaranteed to be true but alleged
Europe's nations should be guided
towards the super state without their
people understanding what is happening
this can be accomplished by successive
steps each disguised as having an
economic purpose by which but which will
irreversibly lead to Federation now that
may be or may not be what he said that's
it I can't guarantee it's been said
widely but the verification is doubtful
but that's exactly what happened that's
the important thing
this is exactly how it happened exactly
how Britain got involved and other
countries it's being done by subterfuge
some people argue that the creation of
the euro is if absolutely a currency
with faults built into it almost because
every time the fault is exposed the call
is greater Union greater Union the
solution is greater Union a banking
crisis here greater Union another crisis
greater Union getting towards that
federal state and so this is exactly how
it has happened and it certainly fooled
the British including me because I voted
to go in because when we opened it was
the European Economic and
unity which was a 550 million person
market with no tariff barriers so
believing in free trade and all that we
thought this is one right on our
doorstep this would be fantastic so even
people like me were hoodwinked into
voting for it and then of course it got
worse and worse and the first thing we
began to see in England was how the
European Union was going to divide as
part of the getting rid of all nations
first of all get rid of the nations and
the second step is eradicating even any
memory of the nations so getting rid of
Britain they were going to divide us
into 11 regions Scotland was small
enough to be one Wales was one Northern
Ireland was one but England was going to
be divided into those eight regions you
say which already now exists thanks to
the Labour government but the people
voted after creating these regions and
each of them reporting directly to
Brussels Westminster the national
parliament totally bypassed so all these
regions were big regions of the European
Union reporting to the Brussels
government not to the British government
and the Labour Party under someone
called be liar that some people call
Blair
he he he got all it's done but the
people revolted when they suddenly said
they want to have all of voting done
this way by region and so it bought that
so Britain sort of sitting in limbo a
bit now with the regions already there
for a lot of administration regional
administration and so on and ready to go
in full blown into the European Union
and then you've got this as a from a
newspaper the des is the complete
eradication those regions were then
going to be teamed with regions in other
countries and you can see how they're
divided there's southwest of Britain
Devon Cornwall endorsed it we're going
to be teamed with with with counties or
regions in Portugal I mean you talk
about representation talk about common
interests in common lifestyle common
culture anything I mean this is
unbelievable
the people in the South of a Mar going
to be turned teamed with people in
northern France but with the French
majority people ought to go with a
Portuguese majority one of the biggest
things was to get rid of any memory of
the British Isles because they were
always the thorn in the side that was
sort of in the
European Union but not not in the euro
not in the Schengen plan and what just
got to get rid of Britain more than
anywhere else and so this was the plan
and and this is what was now you can't
get these things off the internet
they've all been taken down this is a
surreptitious plan the even Eastern
European Coal and Steel community
perfectly sensible after the war Europe
was smashed to try and get a market of
500 million people well then it was
about 300 million was the Soviets had
half of it to get together with no
tariff barriers on it that was a good
thing European Economic Community for
which I voted was also a good thing
because it was a big market with no
tariff barriers then it sort of morphed
into the European community and
suspicions started to arise and I was in
Parliament at time and asked questions
and say why was the missing e and
embarrassed ministers would say oh yes I
mean European Economic Community having
to City Economic Community and of course
Thatcher was on our side she she
believed in EE C and then in European
Union which was absolutely blatant and
of course my belief and this is where
you've gotta take it with a pinch of
salt is that Germany was as a young
country created in the 19th century very
potent people the Germanic peoples I
mean 90 percent of the Praetorian Guard
of the Caesars of Rome were Germanic the
German tribes erratic eradicated totally
three legions of the of the Roman army
in in two days so that no survivors came
out and the site of the battle was lost
until about I think it was six years ago
I saw on the History Channel
some British officer found the site but
the site of the battle was lost to
history
it was so total and so Germany has
always been after Empire the trying to
conquer France in the franco-prussian
war to grab the French Empire had failed
second first world war
again they very nearly got both the
French and British Empire's after that
because we were teetering on a defeat
before the Americans
into the war in 1917 and that they very
nearly succeeded in and you'll see in my
book on the Romanovs whole history of
that and the second world war Hitler
openly said leoben's Ron we want Empire
we want living room living room for the
German people and they protected Europe
for a thousand years from the hordes
from the East almost 2,000 years and so
there are very tough and productive
dedicated people I mean you only have to
look at the things they produce
motorcars
vacuum cleaners whatever it is they work
unlike most of the British one and the
UK joins what was the economic community
but had now become the common market and
Ted Heath was an arch globalist forest
goddess in the Labour government which
was amazing under Wilson actually had
the integrity to hold a confirmational
referendum and the vote was to stay and
I have to say I voted for that my soul
so we didn't see it at that time but the
question gradually dawned on people was
it the European Union or the euro Soviet
if you look at the Soviet Union as an
elected parliament no effective power
it's exactly what happened in Europe
there are great big elections to the
European and Parliament but the
Parliament has no power except
ridiculous powers like approval of the
budget you can't approve any item or any
line-item you have to approve everything
or nothing
and of course nobody wants to bring the
whole budget done so nobody says in it
I'm they talk but they don't vote so
it's exactly as an appointed Politburo
in Europe as an appointed commission of
honor unelected people right the way
through unaccountable unelected and
shielded with vast salaries tax free and
all that sort of stuff and shielded from
suits you can't get at them political
courts have seen numerous example of
political decisions by courts in Europe
and financial corruption rife I mean the
accounts of the European Union haven't
been signed by the auditors for twin
eighty-three years and I mean which
corporation which individual would get
away with unsigned accounts for a year
or two you'd be behind bars but this
all-powerful thing just is okay so the
accounts going to sign why would the
European Union need 2000 bank accounts
if there weren't surreptitious payments
going to Hitler and visitor and
untraceable this and they you know
that's what I mean by corruption and
exactly the same as Europe now they it's
a super state this is the first great
experiment as Europe the war you know
single super state 500 million people
Democratic deficit even the German
Constitutional Court the most powerful
court in Germany calls it that the
Democratic deficit of the European Union
has its own currency the euro
thank God Britain's not in that its own
national anthem now talking about having
its own army and that's where they're
keeping very quiet in the moment because
that's got the British very worried
tough German soldiers marching around in
Britain that would be sort of
politically embarrassing and hot so they
all been played down but Merkel thinks
that once the brexit thing is sorted out
they're going to go straight for it
European police what were the British
population think of having German police
and people in Britain and it will be
just like the Roman Empire you never
used national police and forces on that
country
the British had people from Italy Greece
and everywhere else because they're
going to be much more severe on the
local population there will be local
people who've got families and things in
the in the population nuclear deterrent
the second most powerful in the world in
terms of penetration is in Britain and
that would go to the European Union if
you notice after the Second World War
the two main belligerence Germany and
Japan were forbidden to have nuclear
weapons and this is Germany's way into
getting them is to get Britain in it's a
very important completely hidden counter
that Germany wants that British to
terror the largest financial center in
the world I mean New York is the largest
stock market Japan is the second
England's the London is the
largest stock market but we had in
foreign exchange which trades in
trillions a day not billions trillions a
day 80% of the world's gold bullion
market is in London insurance shipping
all that it is the largest financial
center in the world would go to the
European Union these are huge prizes the
permanent seat on the United Nations
Security Council both France and Britain
have a seat
so they'd certainly get one if not both
and of course
Britain is the head of the Commonwealth
with 1.2 trillion billion sorry trillion
1.2 billion people with influence not
control and the British began to see
that this stuff was going away fear some
of the you army and so on and feeling
that the government of Europe was
overbearing getting into every part of
their lives and giving instructions for
a Moute unaccountable unknown in many
respects people in Brussels
for example the Brighton Beach was no
longer to be called a beach that British
bananas were not straight enough and
saying they've straightened up since
because we've been in European Union but
I mean it was people began to think this
is ridiculous what are we doing with
some bureaucrat in Brussels these
bananas I loved all my life and they're
told they're not to be imported anymore
because they're not straight enough I
couldn't care less whether they're
straight all you shape doesn't buy me
and this began to get in a United
Kingdom but also in countries like Italy
in Greece Hungary and Poland and so the
movement wasn't just in Britain that was
getting upset with this thing and it
gradually dawned on the British people
that this was really a terrible thing
and you Kipp grew the party from nothing
very difficult to start new parties
these days and the Labour Party took
something like 30 years to get members
apart to get a government and then
suddenly lo and behold Nigel Faraj
starts a party five and a half weeks
before the European election and swamps
everybody he's the largest British party
in the European Union Poland pushing the
Conservatives into fifth
place the ruling parties pushed into
fifth place I mean so it's amazing
things can happen when people really get
to understand and the Internet is
crucial to the people beginning to
understand information and knowledge was
controlled by the elite before the
Internet and so you know Duncan we took
27 get the seats we just are the eroded
the conservative vote in 22
constituencies and the Conservatives
lost so we took 20 seats away from them
rather than getting them ourselves
Duncan promised a national referendum
when this looked like it was going out
and then the post when he got in scraped
in he didn't give it but then it looked
like he was having even worse than the
next election so he gave us this
referendum and totally European it's me
all right over a piece of cake you know
but all these polls say we're gonna win
by miles and it is fantastic and he gets
swamped suddenly breaks it and then May
comes along a remainer
she voted remain and says I want to
increase my majority believed all the
polls if she went now she'd get a
hundred seat majority instead of six or
seven and made it up with a minority
government because she believed the
polls and so it was beginning an amazing
chaos and embarrassing cows made the
article 50 you're allowed two years by
the rules but of course this is
unprecedented uncharted territory it's
the final thing if we get out on the
31st of October there have been a 40
month delay when the maximum really and
the rule book was 24 she's given up a
lot of trump cards you know giving away
all sorts things a nuclear deterrent all
these things slightly hinted at already
agreeing to pay a fine of 50 billion
dollars and we're the second largest
contributor to the European Union all
his sort of stuff and she now she's
presided over total chaos in Parliament
she had the largest defeat in British
parliamentary history for any government
business and has came back against all
the rules in 1604 the rule has been you
can't present the same item to
Parliament the same Parliament you've
got a dirty if you want to do it again
it's got to be another Parliament
she produced it again thanks to a
conniving speaker who also voted remain
on a great critic of brexit he allowed
her to do it broke all the rules
she is Jen defeated and then defeated
again and she tried were the fourth time
offering a referendum a second
referendum that's like when your horse
doesn't win the Kentucky Derby say oh oh
sorry sorry let's run the race again
he had a spat start so he slipped at the
start so let's run the race again I mean
our system can't run like that and so
she offered this second render and
having promised it would never pass her
lips in order to get people boat the
fourth time but she rose again defeated
the fourth time and pulled it so it's
been a very unpleasant situation now
Britain one side forgot a but it is
difficult I have to admit there's things
that I listed there on a waste time
reading them because I want to get to
your questions
but that the last one the UK has not
just a special relationship with the
United States but as president Trump has
said a very special the very special
relationship with the United States and
that will vanish because England will
vanish I mean there will be no more
England there's to be a Wales or
Scotland or maybe a Northern Ireland
mainland will vanish from the history
books
it'll be these eight regions which once
was England and so that matters
tremendously to the United States
because England which basically runs the
United Kingdom is the most fervent and
most powerful financially and nuclear
wise American ally so and it's a list to
say nothing of the morale morale support
and the bringing in usually of parts
other the remaining parts of the Empire
before these revolutionaries got going
of Canada Australia New Zealand or to
call the five eyes and so it's a
commitment very complex and dramatic but
did you ask yourself is it worth all
this cost of distortion of markets and
authorizing but do you added RP
do you want your own legal system the
legal system is the fundamental
the contributor to a culture and the
British legal system has juries it has
habeas corpus it has the onus of proof
you're innocent until proved guilty all
these sort of things and it was copied
and taken to the America great stuff
code Napoleon is entirely different
once you're accused you have to prove
your innocence so someone can come along
with very little money and accuse you of
something you then got to spend a
fortune proving you didn't do it which
is not harder than saying someone
proving you did do it and they have had
no habeas corpus you can rot in a jail
in Europe for two or three years but
never ever no charge brought against you
and never appear in court but you just
sit in jail I mean I've had constituents
who've been taken for traffic offenses
on their holidays summer holidays in
Spain and Italy and think a year and
more in jail no not even a charge and
and of course the onus of proof and of
course jury system which is a most
important thing put your own currency
Britain has done so well it's the second
fastest growth rate in European Union
the lowest unemployment and the lowest
interest rates in the whole of Europe of
the Union with its own currency
Defense Force police immigration all
that stuff you know and immigration is a
big issue as it's becoming in the United
States now I mean people do not want
they want immigration but they want
legal immigration not just squat what
has happened I see quite clearly and
Gorbachev said to me once in argue one
of these things you know that you know
if you keep on I was the vice chairman
of the Human Rights Committee and NATO
the North Atlantic assembly was the
political arm of NATO and he said if you
keep on about this Helsinki agreement
the free movement of people are swamped
you with immigrants and this is what's
happened they didn't use the weapons of
mass destruction they've used the weapon
of mass immigration and it's a real real
problem so quickly I've got to get on
quickly just to the positions on brexit
fairly clear they are
to overturn the referendum they want to
appear and this is most important appear
to get out but actually not get out they
want to make the apparent appearance
that it's all we're getting out they
want project fear telling us even now
there's going to be chaos in these
markets you won't get any medical
supplies you won't get any milk or
whatever it is just to frighten people
and a possible second referendum and
then we come down to that link which I'm
going to mention a moment the freight
brexit the brexit ears want out as far
the people's will Deal or No Deal but
the time is running out that will be
even be a deal and how can you make a
deal when the European Union said we're
not going to negotiate them and how do
you get a deal when they other side says
they had not prepared to talk and of
course the euro Soviets once the British
in because a huge prize if you're German
you've been paying all the bills they
like they were the number one pair
Britain was number two leaves a huge
thing when the second-largest pair
leaves and the you've got a start and
here it's the largest car market in
Europe for German cars is Britain and of
course they have all these things like
the nuclear deterrent of trading center
of the financial all that stuff that I
listed before huge Germany does not want
us to go in but in order to discourage
anybody else following Britain out these
feelings as I said before in Greece
Italy Spain and even in France with
lepen and even in Germany when the
alternative of Deutschland came from
zero seats to 80 seats for nothing in in
Germany this feeling all over Europe
against what I'm talking about
and so they see anybody daring to ask
has to be punished
fifty billion dollar fine for daring to
ask and you're going to have all these
things so they want to make an example
of us so they've been constant delays
because of the thing and so basically
for a my United States these are the
implications and they're very very
important to the United States so nobody
knows what the solution is going to be
at the moment it looks like Boris
Johnson will win the Parliament the
Conservative Party's elections and yet
all his scandals some remain as recorded
a rogue a on in his house in London with
his his girlfriend and that became mean
he lost a lot of points in the polls
again I don't know where this reality
but the polls sort of showed it was so
it's still a very tough fight he's by no
means a walk
a shoo-in that he looked only a week ago
but if he gets in on the 22nd of July
when the final votes will be counted
that's the beginning of the
parliamentary holidays so we're away for
a month then September is the conference
season party conferences so no
Parliament so you're pretty much into
October
but either time Parliament will
reassemble and then you're in the five
weeks you've got about four yes you've
got about twenty four government days of
business to get this thing done so the
odds and the huge pressures are going to
be brought on Boris Johnson to push it
back to do a deal to put all this thing
that made it and so it's up to him and
the great question is would he do it or
will he just let brexit happen because
article 50 has been thing and it comes
into law and midnight on the 31st of
October and so there we are now maze
conduct the last thing I'm going to talk
about goodadministrator little emotional
IQ I mean she certainly doesn't know how
to flirt like like like like Margaret
Thatcher did Margaret Thatcher flirted
with Ronnie Reagan very successfully
with Gorbachev very successfully but
when you see the films of May coming
over on her first visit to see President
Trump and he very kindly as they're
walking away under the colonnade he puts
it grabs her hand or right hand and
instead of looking up at something
tapping him left hand she good god yeah
and so that didn't go down too well and
I pretty much sure that that lost us the
possibility of the trade deal at that
time Oh seriously Trump Trump's
emotional gun and and those sorts of
things amongst leaders matter and I
think he did it he played the ace of
trumps when he came to
and is on a state visit last month or
earlier this month he said right if
Britain has a clean
No Deal exit the door zone you'll get
the best trade deal with the United
States of any country in the world and
that demolished in one stroke a lot of
the naysayers pleading that soul is
going to be to the economic disaster
America is still the largest economy in
the world by miles
I mean China's just around half just
over half of the United States economy
European Union if you pull all 27
countries is near the United States but
it's not all one country so if we try to
punish us in Europe by not trading you
know we have an adverse trade balance
with most of the major trading nations
of Europe like adverse with Germany
Germans still want to sell their washing
machines and cars into Britain they
don't want to lose that market so
they're gonna negotiate Britain will be
able to negotiate with each of these
countries individually but it will also
be able to negotiate with countries that
the European Union has no relationships
with European Union has a relationship
with Japan trading agreement a semi
agreement with Canada nothing with the
United States nothing with China nothing
with Australia nothing with New Zealand
and nothing with India so all his
markets are open to Britain to trade it
particularly the United States so Trump
played as I say the ace of trumps he put
it on the table and that everyone was
shocked or they should be as I said she
delayed as you can inserted the Irish
backdrop as a red herring withdrawal
agreement as a sham because what it does
she says oh I promise I'll give you her
exit I was actually in the house at her
first Prime Minister's Questions after
the brexit referendum and I had a
wonderful seat I was on the floor the
house called undercroft just behind the
Speaker's chair you're just divided from
the members of parliament by wooden
shutter you know you've been almost you
can't touch them I mean you're right
there you get the music of the house and
I was quite convinced that she meant
what she said we're going to do Breck
see I spoke to Boris Johnson our tours
in several of my former poly
who was still brickster as they all
convinced she was going to do but what
the clever things she's done is say
right we'll have a remain menu but we'll
call it brexit so Britain under the half
package which he calls brexit and this
is what's so confusing people say well
why they're voting against brexit when
they ask for breaks it but it was a real
get out this is a sham that will be just
giving the appearance of leaving but the
backdrop and all that so actually still
they're ready for any future globalist
prime minister to get straight back in
will still subject to the rules and
regulations
we're subject to British law is going to
be still subject to European law and
which is a code Napoleon and totally
different to ours culturally and so it
was a fake I mean it's really a scanner
so you can await for some pretty big
stuff coming down the line I think
exciting days ahead anyway
[Applause]
that gender I see first we are told that
sentiment to remain is much stronger and
it is the prevailing sentiment in
Scotland why is that that's a very
interesting question as my mother was
Scottish oh the the Scots the British
Scots have always been wanting to get
into England my family is called black
Douglas well he was called black Douglas
by the English the Scottish called in
Douglas the good because he was always
raiding into England and things like
that and his heart Lord when he was
dying Macbeth said to Lord Duggars carve
out my heart and take it to the Holy
Land and that's why they were still in a
coat of arms and so Scotland has always
been after getting away from England or
if not looting and doing this it's been
a problem area as I think it was Cheston
said the finest sight to a Scotsman is
the high road to England because
England's been pouring money in there to
stop them leaving and because it laid
open England's always been frightened
since the Reformation and turning
Protestant that Catholic countries like
France Spain and then would try to get
England back and Scotland was the route
that they might take and so he has
always been terrified of it pouring lots
of money into Scotland the Black Watch
don't know there see anybody here in
that tartan but it's the most popular
tartan in the world was called the Black
Watch because they were Highlanders
recruited by the British to keep eyes on
the Scots the opposite of black Douglas
we think this black was just good and
they think it was terrible and so as
Scotland wants to get away from England
basically and to be trumped up and
therefore if you're in new European
Union they're small enough to be a
region so they would be a self-contained
read read England's going to be divided
into eight so Scotland would still be a
region but reporting not to Westminster
but to Brussels and as a less developed
area because it
very thin soil and agricultural problems
and you've got to keep people on the
land lots of money German and British
money English money coming from Brussels
it's gone so if I was Scottish
I could understand why they voted to go
that but a lot of it is I I think
they're wrong and you knows I'm biased
but I think it's not really in their
interests in their freedom they they're
now almost more Protestant than the
British Protestants and so when they've
got a dough to Roman Catholic type
things in Europe and they're law legal
system is in a way more refined than the
British they've got to completely
abandon that they're not going to have a
very happy time but that's the answer to
your question dot a whole answer because
everyone will have different reasons
that those are the main reasons that
they think they're going to do better by
remaining in by being independent much
of your fascinating presentation was on
the matters of sovereignty and culture
and not until the end
did you really focus on the economic
impact one of the articles of faith of
American conservatism has always been
that free trade is an inherently good
value to to pursue internationally isn't
the UK's trade position threatened by a
departure from the common market all of
the EU information that I think the
average American has is focused on trade
not culture not not sovereignty and the
implication is that the trade would be
diminished and that that would be
economically disastrous and as a sort of
subset question the size of the London
financial community which you address
the greatest single economic for
in the world would be not only vastly
but quickly diminished with brexit
because so many of the financial
corporations would in fact leave London
and go to Europe are those in any way
valid points and how would you fit them
into your picture of of being in safer
brexit two point straightest different
financial operations but first of all on
trade yes that's exactly the argument
put by the people against brexit is
it'll be a fearsome and terrible thing
but I'm like President Trump I'm not
just a free trade I'm for free and fair
trade without tariffs differentials
between countries which were all
organized by these global people I want
free and fair trade and therefore I
think Britain has shown in the past
we've been excommunicated from Europe
before we were excommunicated when Henry
the fifth broke from the Church of Rome
and we were barred from Europe basically
we were educated by our own blockades in
the Napoleonic Wars and the First World
War and the Second World War so we've
been thrown out and denied access to
Europe on four major occasions and
that's what forced Britain to look
elsewhere around the world
this little coaling stations like to
brought on Malta series and all that on
the way to India and all around the
world little bits and gradually assem
part got built up which was a third of
the surface area of the world and a
third of the population of the world
from an island not much bigger than
Florida and so it was an amazing thing
and the British have been able to look
abroad anding and today all our old
trading partners New Zealand Australia
Canada America have been barred offer us
a lot by the tariffs of the European
Union
no Towson pretty much in European Union
or there are terrorists but not very
severe so those are we denied but as I
was tried to say before
the very countries the French still want
to sell products of cheese the Germans
want to sell their cars into the British
market where we've got trade deficits so
we buy more from them than they buy from
us so why would they want to get rid of
us
they actually individually they're all
for the team yes right Britain's got to
be in but when you come down to
individual negation okay we will deal
with you you know and as I said Trump
just put the card down I mean the best
trade deal in America ever for any
country in the world he said if you have
a clear exit I mean what a prize there
he offered he really stoned
that argument because that's the biggest
market in the world and all Britain has
to do now is compete of course it's very
cozy when everything's next door you go
and see your Marvin you just jump in a
little private jet up across to Paris or
rather and for corporations is even
American corporations instead of having
27 headquarters the one for each country
have one europe emea quarters customs
but of course the economics isn't
culture and it's not morale and it's not
national spirit which is what we're
talking about is the population against
global control I'm in a global free
market will look very attractive and
then you look at finance and that is
almost a global market but financial
markets are starting I mean the Chinese
are trying to take from London the gold
bullion market and have it based in in
the Far East a lot of Far East and
growth is ebbing away taking stuff from
Europe
Europe's heading for recession and
what's happened is that a lot of the
goodies of Europe now and and a lot of
the financial activity is debt markets
the debt market is huge because European
Union has taken quantitative easing to a
new level I mean they're really doing
you a big time and so if the market in
London is in euro debt it's a huge
market and of course a lot of that will
ever cross to the continent and those
investment banks and banks that are
heavily dealing in European debt may
well want to go to Frankfurt and for the
moment some of their people have moved
to Frankfurt but they will come back to
England for the weekend because they
don't like to live in Franklin they like
London and so you know there's much more
to a financial market than just contact
with the market does the accounting
division processing the technology of
the speaking and doing that deals
themselves of the exchanges it takes
years to build a major financial center
like that and I just don't see Frankfurt
or Paris taking you from London in the
longer term the beginning of course that
one then start to head backward
especially the tie between London and
New York is for I mean it's fantastic
big vast same language same legal system
everything London in New York they
dominate the finances of the West and
one of those were broken the others
together those two and Trump Caesar and
that's why I said he realizes what I
said America's going to lose if we don't
get corrected they've got to stick
together together we succeed and divided
with forward and that's what is it about
and the financial thing its debt and my
god that do the Germans won the British
that's why the Germans are constantly
fighting against taking responsibility
for the day because the German ethos for
its population has been right you work
hard
we'll pay you in cash money and we in
return for that hard work we will make
sure your money is real and ever since
the diamond republic on the certainly
since the Second World War
that has been true and the deutsche mark
went up and up and up and up so they
they my god is too strong it's hurting
our exports let's this think about
joining this European currency and the
French sought up the echo and then they
said when the three powers the United
States Russia or the four and Britain
but we allowed France to be in there
escaping across their sectors and other
than part of Arizona's the roughest in
the arena fication of Germany Prince if
we don't win degree until they joined
the European Council
so the euro was born on the Germans are
in their marvelous for their exporters
purple is cheaper than the deutsche mark
would it be
but it's riveting in its and then with
all this debt and they keep asking the
Germans to be more responsible for
backing out with Germany's in the world
[Music]
I thank you for your presentation what
what you member would you predict would
leave next what you member would you
predict would leave next and why a what
new member of the European Union will
leave yes I don't know I mean I really
don't know that that it's tough enough
to know in Britain whether where the
votes are especially we're living in
Florida you know people ask me is Boris
going to win I'm and I hear
my friends in England things like but
you know you've got to be in the house
talking to people you know which were
you gonna vote was right even the whips
turn now and there that could the KGB of
the Conservative Party really know
what's going on in those ruthless they
are the case beautiful but even they
don't and they lost control money she
lost three firsts in Parliament by
record amounts just one or the other and
the whips in the Conservative Party are
ruthless to kill people at them to pay
the you this was clean a rebellion
beyond belief in British parliamentary
history and to know what's going to
happen in these other countries I mean
it's a very interesting question but
afraid I've got to go out with saying I
have no real answer
you